countries around the world are fighting
increasingly destructive cyberattacks
wired investigates what it calls the
most devastating cyberattack in history
in its September cover story out this
month the cyber weapon not petia started
in Ukraine in June of 2017 quickly
spread paralyzing major companies and
causing more than 10 billion dollars in
damage senior writer Andy Greenberg
adapted the article from his upcoming
book sandworm about the Russian agents
allegedly behind the attacks
he's here with wired editor-in-chief and
CBS News contributor Nicholas Thompson
for a conversation you'll see first on
CBS this morning gentlemen thank you so
much for joining us and Andy I remember
this attack like so many of us do it
caused major headlines major destruction
yet it was still so underappreciated by
the majority of Americans and people
around the world why was this well you
know that's a devastating attack we
didn't know when this happened at a time
the kind of devastation have actually
inflicted on these companies we heard
that Maersk the world's larger shipping
firm Merck FedEx all had been hit by
this they took months to realize they'd
all suffered hundreds of millions of
dollars in damages and that ultimately
this spread around the world they cost
ten billion dollars by far the biggest
cyber attack in history and the question
is what comes next how do we prevent
another one of these because I don't
think we've seen that guarantee from the
US government or from governments around
the world are you confident that we're
prepared for the next one
I don't think we really can be prepared
to prevent the next one of these this
was a cyber war attack this was Russian
military intelligence hackers unleashing
a piece of malware using zero-day
vulnerabilities vulnerabilities we
haven't patched in our systems that we
maybe can't patch so it spreads
unintentionally to the rest of the world
it was meant to be a cyber war attack on
their enemies in Ukraine so you know
it's very difficult to prevent attacks
from these kind of ultra sophisticated
hackers what we need to do is first send
a message to countries like Russia that
this is unacceptable this kind of
reckless attack can't happen again and
then we need to be prepared to kind of
recover quickly from these massive worms
spread around the world and Nick when we
say we must recover quickly is that the
government who has to do companies have
to and just remind people what it means
to be hacked in this way your computers
turn off are you unable to send email
what's the well what happened in this
hack was amazing all the screens went
black so they were sitting there and one
computer goes down the next computer
goes down the next computer goes down
and so then recovery is a really
important part right so cybersecurity as
you're saying you have to make sure
people can't get in you have to assume
people get in and you can track them
when they're in and then once you knock
do they knock you down you have to go to
get back up my favorite detail in Andy's
piece so Maris goes down and all the
computers have been connected and they
realized oh wait because all these
things call the domain controllers were
connected we can't get the system back
up let's call everybody maybe somebody
was offline and they finally find one
office in Ghana that had had a power
outage so they get the guy to fly to
Nigeria take the disk from Nigeria to
London and that's how they put it back
online in the future companies need to
be prepared for that and maybe don't
rely on a power outage in Ghana can you
can you have a system in which there is
an uninfected machine another one one
that's running parallel but it isn't
connected to the main node well this is
like the the solution not only for
Maersk which is the focus of our story
and all these other companies but for
for regular people as well
backing up your your system making an
offline copy of all of your data is one
way to recover from this when you get
hit with a ransomware attack that
encrypts your entire computer that may
be the only way you can't necessarily
prevent that but you can have that
offline backup as a recovery this kind
of resilience is maybe the solution and
you talk about having to address who
these bad actors are right we know that
most of these were attributed to Russia
the president has yet to specifically
say what he plans on doing as far as
reciprocating if we will at all against
the Russians in fact he wanted to create
a cyber unit with the Russians how
important is it for the US president to
address this I think that's super
important to set a deterrent we saw last
night with Facebook announcing that Iran
is now trying to manipulate America and
why are they doing that well lots of
reasons but one is because there's no
deter
there were no consequences to Russia for
what they did so it's not surprising
that the rest of the world is going to
copy them really interesting information
Andy nickel always good to see you
thanks so much thanks line